hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the other
subjects that Aristotle discusses in
Mechanics book 3 which is worth taking a
look at is what is translated very
difficult Lee as wish or rational desire
laces none of them are really
satisfactory translations but we don't
have anything better than that
this is a fundamental form of
effectivity or axis the broadest term
that Arizona uses for any kind of
activity or desire and along with
appetite and anger or through most it
like I said it's one of those basic
three he doesn't tell us an awful lot
about it in the nick of mechanics he
does tell us a bit more about it
in the rhetoric but I'm going to stick
here just to what it tells us in the
nick of McCann ethics about this
important phenomenon now in the context
he is contrasting it against
deliberation and choice or pro head
races which are different than it in
their you know they're concerned with
means to a given end it's bull ASIS that
among other things
the designer for the end that says
that's what it is that I want over there
you know deliberation and choice are
concerned how do I get over there so
wish is for I could put here it's
exclusively for as Aristotle says ends
it doesn't really concern itself with
with means and the way that he depicts
it in certain respects kind of gives you
the impression that it's in certain ways
a little bit some pie in the sky you
might say or imaginative it imagines
ends that it can't possibly attain or
achieve it represents that aspect of
desire that goes way beyond the possible
way beyond what is realizable by us like
I have here on the board we can wish for
things that are indeed impossible
Aristotle he has as an example
immortality like that of the gods you
know not something that the Greeks
thought was or at least Aristotle
thought was up to human beings I suppose
some people did did in fact think that
but it's a sort of thing when you can
say yeah I realize I can't have that but
I really do want it and wouldn't it be
great if I if I could attain that and we
have all sorts of you know wishes like
that that are essentially unrealizable
you know think about people's romantic
ideas about the ideal partner who they
are searching for mr. right or mrs. mrs.
Reiter
I suppose mrs. right after you know
she's been misery or something like that
and you know they've got all this stuff
that they're never actually been to do
that and sometimes it can be quite
counterproductive if you have ends that
you know keep occupying you from
pursuing other ends that would be
realizable for you not all now that all
the things that we wish for are
unrealizable many of them are Aristotle
uses as an example health it is possible
for us to be healthy now he is for
everybody
but you know the people who are actually
sitting
not going to get any better can still
wish for help they can still desire it
Aristotle thinks that happiness your dad
Juanita is something that we have a wish
for as well although people will
conceive of it in different ways one
thing and as we've seen there's a whole
video secrets on that so we wish for
things that are impossible
we can also wish for things that are not
really up to us they're possible but
they're contingent upon what other
people do or how things turn out you
know somebody might say no I could just
win the lottery my life would you know
all fall into place and in that case I
understand that you could say they're
treating the lottery and the winnings as
a means to an end of the happiness but
sometimes people can get fixated just up
if I won the lottery right and whether
you win the lottery or not okay so they
do say you got a pay-to-play
right you can't actually win if you
don't buy a ticket but if you do buy a
ticket you're probably grateful bit
somebody's going to win but odds are
it's not going to be you unless you
count you know perhaps getting a $5 pay
off or something like that
in general lottery tickets are a bad
investment all you have to do is at
least in the United States look at the
band where they show you the odds and
you can see that it is really not up to
us for peacenik see them games of chance
that's why we call them games of chance
but there's all sorts of other things
where we might have wishes for things
and they're not really up to us consider
for example having a happy family life
when you've got a bunch of people in
your family who can't get along with
each other
now you could you know exert all of your
effort and activity to try and get them
on the same page but it's ultimately not
up to you you can still have that desire
and in fact having that desire is a good
thing Aristotle would say it's just not
going to be a realized desire so we have
those desires that are four things that
are impossible with desires four things
that are possible but just not up to us
then we have desires are things that are
up to us at least to some extent now
Aristotle asks a very interesting
question and considers two different
possible ways of looking at this before
saying that there's something wrong with
both of them and we have to combine them
together into a better account what are
we actually wishing for whether wishing
for something we're regarding it as a
good that's why to be desired
that's why we wish for it right it's as
long as fundamental kinds of orientation
or desire activity do we only wish for
what is the actual good you could say
well look aerosol says all people desire
happiness so therefore they really are
desiring something that is a genuine
good but then aerosol could say as he
does
not everybody understands you happiness
in the same way they imagined it to be
something different some a lot of people
they just imagined it to be a life of
pleasure right hedonistic life so is is
what is which for only what is the
actual good aerosol says that doesn't
make sense people wish for all sorts of
things that are not actually good they
have all sorts of desires for things
that might be good at some respect but
not good you know in general for people
they desires things sometimes that are
good in general but not actually for
them as such you know and some people
actually desire things that are that are
bad why because they're vicious you know
they they want to for example dominate
others to the exclusion of the the
others from deliberative decision-making
or you know genuine friendship or
something like that if you sever them as
a wish there's something wrong there
that's not a genuine good so here's the
lenses well another possibility is
perhaps what is wished for is only what
appears good to the one who's wishing
for them and he raises a problem with
that
he says they would be forced to admit
there is no such thing as that which is
by nature wished for but that which each
man thinks to be good is wished for in
his case yet different and it may be
opposite things appear good to different
people if we accept this notion
expressed by the other one that what is
wished for what fundamentally Orient's
us in our you know towards ends that we
then seek means for in our choices it is
only the apparent good then all we have
left is apparent goods and there is no
real good there is no common good for
humankind it's just whatever he happens
to be in the eye of the beholder
relative eyes is the good to such an
extent that how can we even call
anything good at that point we can only
say good for this person or good for
that person Aristotle says well we can
give around this by saying we're going
to make a distinction there it is what
is wished for unqualifiedly and when we
translate unqualifiedly in this case is
this Greek term hotwheels which means
something like simply or per se and
Aristotle seems to think that that is
what is Rishabh 'el that that is what we
want to be wishing for doesn't mean that
it actually is what any given person is
wishing for there's always going to be
some people who are wishing for it
because there's always some good
properly oriented people but it may be
in any given culture that many of the
people are not wishing for that and they
actually regard the people who are to be
stupid or backwards or you know
hopelessly naive or something like that
right and then there is what is wished
for by a given person now Aristotle is
going to use an analogy here that's
quite interesting he says accordingly
that the good man wishes wishes for what
is truly wished for the bad man for
anything has
yeah just as in the case of our bodies a
person of sound Constitution finds
really healthy food best for their
health they they have whether they're
making an explicit judgement or it's
just on the basis of their their desires
and then their responses but some of
their diet may be healthy for one who is
delicates and so with things bitter and
sweet hot heavy and etc the good man
judges everything correctly what things
truly are that they seemed to him to be
in every department for the bad person
though they're going to be misled so
their their desires for ends are going
to be off base they're going to desire
some things that they should which
appear good to them but aren't truly
good in themselves they may be good just
to the limited circumstances they may
not in fact be good at all they may be
good by week by means of being you know
a way to attain in other goods they may
be useful goods but not you know genuine
you know cologne goods like for example
when somebody becomes a miser and they
just desire money money money money
money
Chesterton by the way has a really
interesting observation about about my
about misers in one of his works where
he says that the miners of the past
could at least be forgiven because you
know they want a gold and you can hold a
bowl in your hands and it's quite pretty
so there is some pleasure to be derived
from it at least not as much pleasures
you can get like buying things with it
which is what's a smart person you know
who's not a miser we did the the
practically smart person but at least
you know you can understand they they
like that [ __ ] they like the luster of
it right not the same thing for numbers
in a ledger or in our you know accounts
online as we do it nowadays to be that
sort of miser is to be somebody who
loves zeros as many zeros as possible so
long as there's some number in front of
it to begin with but it's not to love
something that is genuinely lovable it's
not the designer
that's genuinely for its own sake
desirable as an end so Aristotle is
saying here that there's an analogy
between the sick person and the healthy
person and you might say the the morally
well-developed person and the person
who's got some some growing in to do
some work to do upon themselves let
alone the person who's really fallen
outside the bounds of you know the
virtues and has fallen into vices the
vicious person is going to desire
they're lying things and that's part of
what makes them vicious so this is a
very important aspect of human nature
like I said it's part it's one of the
main forms of effectivity for us and it
worries us towards these ends which then
we have to find the means for through
things like deliberation and choice